we're going to do a huge fight because
she ate my ass and I came so quick okay
yeah this is gold yeah this is gold
oh
what the hell's the bartender
we don't need them we don't need them I
need a drink all right Sam needs a drink
I like this new studio man that's all
you need it's good to see you man and
this is a shared space right so it's not
even that [__] expense not like no
this is all ours no but I'm saying
outside oh yeah yeah yeah exactly
garbage has a [__] compound I know I
know compound but it's good yeah they're
huge talking about Foley
he's a big smoker oh yeah dude uh last
time I saw you was in the Nick game oh I
know that was [__] brutal brutal I
was on the street last night after the
loss and I'm wearing a Nick sweatshirt
and some guy goes I'm in my moons just
like like let me just eat away the pain
yeah and some guy walks up to me goes
hey Sam why don't you take that
sweatshirt off after that game I don't I
ignore him because I'm like in a bad
mood and he says again hey Sam I said I
go I heard you yeah I go I [__] heard
you and you just go okay and walked away
that's the one something about celebrity
is they get I'm not a celebrity but you
know what I mean you know but you are to
people he knew you so he goes hey hey
good job or great set Sam that's nice
but hey Sam yeah your Nick suck I'll
match your energy there you go if you
say good set I'll say thanks right are
you doing a protein shake yeah is that
stupid I mean it's a drinking podcast
what I'm saying you look great though by
the way I can only because I gotta cut
my eating hours Stop in about 40 minutes
here so I just got to get in the last
hour we'll get you some calories are you
intermittent yeah oh you changed my
whole life I do it too literally but you
but see the thing do you really I well I
do it on accident I was gonna say you've
always the P what I've learned is and I
bet Sam doesn't the people who have
always maintained he can use some
fasting the people can always
the people who can who who always like
had good builds like you and Sam always
naturally didn't I realized like I have
to force myself to do it or I'm not
gonna stay in line my metabolism so now
I pretty much eat 10 a.m to 6 sometimes
11 to 5 depending on the hours and yeah
dude it changed my whole [__] what do
you mean before it was just you would
snack before bed you mean before I was
just I had no rules I would just eat
like you know my daughter would you know
my kids be eating it'd be seven o'clock
I'd be eating a little bit of their
pasta a little bit of their desserts
like I'm not eating that much but it
doesn't matter your body's metabolism is
kicking in and you're breaking out of
your fasting even if you have anything
over 30 calories so I was never in a
state of calorie deficit and my body was
never burning my body was never burning
it's fat right it was always like you
know so so so now I do now I go I don't
even know what he's 16 to 18 hours with
no eating are you down for Manhattan or
no sure you can't make that whatever's
easiest to make well he can't make a
Manhattan are you really making a
pentatonic once
really your wife drinks Manhattans
what who's your wife Humphrey Bogart you
kind of look like Philip Seymour Hoffman
in a way in a little way
but it's his career that's dead
oh yeah I mean you look like Hoffman now
he was the best I mean honestly I was
watching the other night Along Came
Polly he's so
funny
I mean Baldwin too the second scene in
the movie
it's on the floor is [__] so funny
yeah raindrop I mean some of the work
terms that we use like sharding how we
just that's from that movie no the first
time you ever heard the term sharding
Phillips
it is
before Oh that was raindrop
that's in Manhattan right isn't that by
the seller is that the one in the West
Village no no no
is it I thought I could be wrong
Sasquatch
oh I gotta P for you basketball related
I was playing on the road and this dude
was shirtless which I was just like he
just takes his shirt off mid game and
I'm like I gotta guard the shirtless wet
slippery that's a tactic wet wet man
that's a peeve wet man Tiki Barber told
me that a tactic for some of the players
uh in the NFL when he was playing was to
not shower to smell like absolute [__]
because he said you had a lot of people
who like they would smell so bad or not
brush their teeth or just be disgusting
that you would kind of think twice about
having that guy roll on you or like
taking it to him so he was like I people
that was like a tactic for people to be
not hygienic okay wow huh that makes
sense then he told me a funny story once
about the Cleveland Browns about how
they played the Browns on like one of
those like um uh Saturday early
afternoon games like during the ended up
you know play towards the playoffs
towards the end of the regular season
and they played the Cleveland Browns and
you know they beat the [__] out of them
and then they weren't going home that
night the Giants they were going to wait
and go home then next morning so they
decided to go out to a nightclub in
Cleveland and they are the Giants so
they all were just like walking in and
he said Tiki Barber was walking in and
forgot some other player was walking in
and they noticed he fumbled his ID yeah
I know no that and they noticed that
Cleveland Browns members of the
Cleveland Browns football team waiting
online to get into the club the people
at their own in their own cities
nightclub wouldn't let them in because
they're like you guys want to just come
in with us and he's like we walked in
the whole team into their own nightclub
oh my God and then the guys were just
saying it was like how much it sucks to
play for that team wow they get no
respect they had that QB Bernie cozar in
the 80s and the guy just got the [__]
kicked out and his dad stole all his
money yes yeah yeah he was on like the
famous broke yeah yeah but he uh he
would cut like eight concussions or
something and the fans are just booing
them like this dude's dying that's how
his dad starts stealing his money
because he was so concussed and [__]
up that his dad was just like this guy's
like my son's a [__] so now so I'm
just gonna take his money it sucks the
worst father ever
that was definitely a good time he gets
another hit he's like that's another 10
grand right there yeah right there
didn't the Jordan's dad die yeah
gambling the Russians killed him I think
I don't know who killed him they have
approved it but possible he was like
pulled off the side of the road the the
conspiracy theory that I don't know if
it's true is that you yeah it's that uh
they asked him to take a break from
basketball because it was getting bad
press and that's why he did the baseball
thing for you oh is that why although
but the baseball was worse than the dad
died
but the thing is it makes no sense to me
that conspiracy theory because he's the
biggest star yeah why would you you'd
want him to play yeah
suspend for gambling right and then he
said are you miked up by the way
oh [__] oh never mind for gambling uh
and they said that's too bad for the
sport so why don't you just take a year
off and say you're retiring right in a
year and then his son died as well
Jordan oh I don't know did he you're
thinking of Cosby
Road shooting Zone both side of the road
shooting sorry yeah Cosby's son was
killed yeah just randomly side of the
road he was changing a tire boom
interesting crazy maybe it was a little
you know one of the victims getting a
little Revenge now you go to sleep
what are you doing again
starter because I don't have ginger ale
for the medicine you put Manhattan
ginger ale and Manhattans what is this
no this is style it's sweet vermouth
Bourbon and Bitters that's all it is
now now I really don't trust no no
where's the pick me up where's the
quarter beer
no the girl oh what's her name she's
nursing oh she got she had a full baby
right oh yeah and she's already back
whoo what's her face uh girl Jamie Jamie
oh yeah couldn't think of her name sorry
the girl she's very hot remember when
pro wrestling there was there was a side
character that would come out uh her
name was a woman that's all they could
come up with is a name like you're a
woman would you do that with the Trans
athletes hey woman
I saw a hot trans walking over here did
you and Eighth Avenue was [__] ripe
with them was she holding hands with Jim
Norton bro it is [__] Norton's new
material about his trans girlfriend is
so funny he's amazing yeah Good comic
you so there's a lot of what on 8th
Avenue it's tons really like yeah
there's a lot of homeless out there
today oh that's crazy well the heat you
know the sun's coming out so they're out
this is a nice building though this is
this is really nice you like it have you
guys been here not that long not a year
I think it's good here it's great we
love it we're parked we're staying we're
staying baby uh you see the trans uh
poker player one no uh some guy said I'm
gonna identify as a woman and he went to
the women's poker and won the toll
tournament oh [__] yeah because women
can't have a good Poker Face they can't
hold me
yeah that write that down
that's true but it's just but but poker
should be even it should be men and
women because it's it's just there's no
physical right but yet the guy still won
so he identified as a woman to enter
damn slippery slope damn this is how
they get you and I think a guy did that
with the weight lifting as well a guy
identified as a woman and won the
weightlifting
yeah sorry I jerk off to this stuff at
all
that's fun so wait yeah how was Sicily
amazing you went with the lady yeah
Sicily was good half Sicilian and um are
we on we're good yeah we're rolling oh
we've been rolling yeah oh we're cooking
baby is this that bad an episode oh you
using this yeah yeah this is the show
actually
um I no Sicily Sicily was great it's um
light Lotus was there why that's where I
stayed in the San Domenico Palace the
same is it really fancy it's really it
was really nice but it was with the kids
as well just no just Jazz and I yeah and
um we had a good time
um I learned something I was asking the
uh the the the Italian Guys whoa that
guy's tall the beer juice there it is
baby what was your uh beard you train
late I got to start being on a motorcade
on the express bus uh is he Mike though
he's Biden in town no I think he died
nice buddy
um I uh and what he said was the this
Italian baggage handler guy I was asking
him questions like what do you see like
like was anything you learned from
seeing all these people come in and out
he goes the people with the most luggage
have the worst time he goes I think the
more luggage people bring and it's
usually Americans always complain always
get into a fight with their wife and
kids always are sitting down in the bar
alone he said people who come with
almost nothing with just like a knapsack
or one little travel or one little
carry-on have a great time it was like
Pack Light that that would be my advice
it's a metaphor for Life yeah you don't
need all this [__] all these material
things you know you just need your
family or friends but who normally
really brings the extra bags women they
need a million ounces woman well that's
what I say that's what I said to him I
was like well because I saw him I was
sitting at the bar by myself I was like
I I brought almost nothing yeah and I'm
having a bad time but I'm having a bad
time because my girl ate my [__] a
few hours ago and then I came in too
quickly and she thinks I'm gay now
that's what I said I was like what are
you talking about like you can't did you
really call you gay yeah she was like
she was like crying she was like this
confirms it and she was just like I
swear to God she was like looking wait
that was the test no yeah she didn't do
it for your pleasure she did it today
our room had like this nice little
balcony and she was like literally
weeping be like this confirms that she
was sipping Prosecco looking out at the
Mediterranean like what am I gonna do
yeah I was like well I'm gonna go
downstairs and find a [__] guy then
on the way out you should have been you
should have walked instead and your
shoes are terrible yes damn but it was
it was great it's the only place that
I've been to where I actually fell in
love with the people you know like when
people say that yeah I never understood
that but I was like oh the people their
way of life not everything is about
money not everything is about the hustle
not everything is about oh I saw this
idea on Shark Tank not everything is
that they're like we just live we make
enough money to live our life and it and
it was sweet I was like well if I took
that attitude I wouldn't be staying in
this [__] hotel so get me get me
another Diet Pepsi
it's always funny when people give you
that advice you're like what is this
2009 yeah yeah oh yeah no dude more at
the [__] white what yeah it was like
four grand a knife what well here's what
I do here's how I live my life because
that does that does sound like a lot of
money and it is yeah but I do one one
trip every 18 months I don't do it every
year I do it every 18 months this was
that trip where I just have a guilt-free
spending trip that I I'm consciously
thinking about taking a percentage of my
income monthly to put towards this
guilt-free spending trip and that was
this mushy made you feel guilty she
called exactly I know I was like I
should have taken Mateo
also are you gay when you're signing
that check at the end huh yeah how gay
am I now lady exactly [__]
unbelievable I'm gay I did pick out the
stucco which is gorgeous in the backyard
though
you're like I'm not gay Now put on this
strap on real quick yeah Peg me yeah but
uh yeah it was good man that doesn't
make you gay that's ridiculous and
there's nothing wrong with being gay by
the way but you can't start well he's
got it all right he's gonna make a real
cocktail all right yes dude sound like
you're really not filling in well yeah
pouring us a quarter Guinness like a
before uh it's like yeah yes sir or like
a little antihistamine and uh 100 dude
you look like like a professional soccer
player or something you look like some
type of Viking guy isn't he a viking you
know they invented [__] on the chest
supposedly really supposedly I don't
know what the Viking leader who it was
specifically but supposedly they would
come in raid and you know your standard
Viking stuff raid pillage rape kill the
kids all that fun stuff but then they
would what some Viking Clans would do is
in in an effort to show dominance they
would keep a couple of people that they
were going to make slaves alive and
before they killed the top Chieftain of
that tribe they would hold him down and
each member of the new Viking Clan would
come and [__] on his chest I could take
that to me it's [__] a chest [__] is
way better than getting raped or
pillaged sure it would suck to feel like
the one constipated Viking
just or blood [__] or you're just
[__] out little rabbit pellets oh
yeah they're getting slimed on
Nickelodeon but even worse yeah damn
that's so I mean although the Germans
decided to make it a sexual thing I
guess yes yeah they made a humiliation
thing but they the Germans and Odell
Beckham enjoys it supposedly yeah
supposedly yes well supposedly they say
he's gay supposedly yeah supposedly he
likes his bucket wonder why I think um
what's his face is um is definitely gay
the way he speaks uh oh God Kevin Spacey
Kevin Spacey's gay me Chrissy D
um I'm I'm blanking somebody it's like
he's so openly gay the Minnesota Vikings
did that when they won the game on the
other team yeah well that's what lizzo
means when she's like boyfriend on the
Minnesota Vikings yeah [__] on the chest
now that would be a scary [__] because
you're like oh God
yeah big dump I'm attracted to lizzo
though he's got a pretty face in some
ways yeah I like her I like her
confidence and energy sure yeah she's
vegan is she oh yeah someone's going
vegan of grass yeah that's a lot she's
got a graze yeah
Gray's Anatomy look at this I bought you
guys gifts
treats from uh Angelina Bakery you guys
ever go there right by your studio here
I don't wanna I don't want it don't
throw it yeah and then I got up you know
what this is you know you know what bugs
me about this yeah this guy comes in
drinking protein shakes working out he's
trying to fatten us up yeah and he
breaks this [__] yeah look at this come
on
pistachio strawberry Nutella and that's
I came in that one well Mark wants a
Nutella I know oh yeah and then I think
that one might be a hazelnut cream or
anything I said I know you guys aren't
fat but your staff is
[Laughter]
I'm a fatty as well I love eating this
[__] I try I try to only eat it on the
weekends which one is that that's like
some hazelnutty uh baby yeah they're all
good man so they're cream filled they're
all cream filled yeah the place is not I
don't want to give away your location
but it's not far from where you are down
the street you know where it is you ever
been there right on it's right on 8th
Avenue it's awesome dude donuts donuts
coffees yeah Italian sandwiches they got
real actual like Italian gelato they
have you know the gelato is real when
they have the rectangular
um you know holders that they have yeah
I know what you mean that's real gelato
I want the Nutella if you don't mind the
Nutella yeah now what are you doing
look at that classic Manhattan kid going
out what are we doing sugar right on the
pants we're real sloths man
that's very good would you like
something yeah anybody oh Peter's I see
you drooling over there
do you really Peters he's like Norm over
there
as well
for the cakes oh wow that's a lot of
Newt yeah oh yeah oh no
it actually comes from a Vikings
butthole right yes thank you my friend
absolutely Sam dirty martini for you oh
what what is everyone else doing I got
up to uh some tequila yeah it's like a
little tequila thank you my friend what
are you doing I'm doing that I'll do
what everyone's doing all right I'm a
team player oh wow yummy in my tummy
yeah wow have you been on the road heavy
uh Chris I just got I just came back
from uh shout out to good people of
Buffalo Ithaca and Albany
um did you go to that restaurant I told
you about no we didn't go I couldn't
make it um but I had food in Ithaca I
went to this place I think it's called
Reds in Ithaca was some of the best food
I've ever had in my life
um it was good but now I'm on I got a
couple more I got one more Dayton
Newport Rhode Island May 28th and then
I'm taking the summer off is that the
road in August Rogue Island yeah that's
a fun fest yeah I'm doing uh my man Doug
key I'm doing two shows there love the
Doug but then yeah summer off and then
uh is that you do that off for your kids
for my kids yeah and for my own I
haven't really taken any time off from
uh since like we got back at it from the
pandemic so I was like let me just take
some time and yeah July June July like
hang with the kids and then August I go
back heavy I got Radio City September
22nd
good boy makes good yeah and then the
theater at Madison Square Garden
September 23rd and then uh yeah baby and
then um and then uh and then I'm gonna
put a fall Tour on sale you know soon
I'm gonna ask for a custom Chrissy D
next Jersey I want it whoa like the path
like like we here's the thing with us
right is we you know you don't know if
it's gonna happen but like we're in you
know Sam and I are New York boys we are
on a pet like you will sell out the Hulu
theater at MSG and then you might even
add a second one probable no but I'm
saying it's probable it's gonna happen
and then you know like the thing again
not that it's gonna happen but we have
an actual chance like it's not out of
the realm of possibility to perform at
like the real Madison Square Garden sure
it's not out of the realm of possibility
it's no it's like there's people who are
in line to do it all three of us are but
it's like as New Yorkers it's like if
that happens it's almost like it's
almost like if that happens then like
where'd he go from there what do you do
what are you even what are you doing
everything else is just like all right
yeah I think weird sex stuff yeah that's
what it is yeah that's when you get into
kids
Drew I mean look at it he had everything
everything where do you go what's your
what's your uh because obviously New
York is where the garden but is it
Garden as well eight your nine year old
I mean the garden is is gross something
about Carnegie really scratches my taint
I love that Carnegie well how many seats
is that 30 000. oh really you could do
that right now no I would love it
usually yeah but I like all the rules I
like the Ryman is is special right
um is there anything in New Orleans
that's like special the Sanger the
Sanger is like our Beacon kind of and I
would love to do the Sanger one day I
open for Schumer there years ago but to
really headline the Sanger would be but
do you think I think you could do it now
I could do it I mean give me three years
it's probably like five thousand seats
is it yeah and that's a lot New Orleans
I know but you I feel like I think where
you're from is a big act
I don't know but I'm like you I they say
never buy your dream car because then
where do you go from there it's
depressing yeah so I like just running
around doing all you would never do you
have a dream car
yeah do you even drive do you even I
don't I don't I got a beamer I got a 73
so I kind of have my dream car oh yeah
do you have a dream car a dream car
um no I have a Lincoln Navigator now
it's pretty nice oh that's very for the
family nice see look at that it's a
sweet ride car oh yeah
thank you
cheers
[Music]
he always he always leans it my way I
love it out of respect for the guest
he's a guest yeah yeah Mark Mark's farts
are cute oh thank you Mark is like kind
of the closest to a cartoon character we
have yes yes tell that to my wife when
she's eating my ass
I'm gay yeah she's eating his ass
Chipotle
comedy because your wife now married guy
do you guys think about like the future
like kids Finance investing do you do
anything totally totally I think all
that stuff's fun I like saving for the
future I like I'm buying a house I'm
buying a brownstone in Brooklyn whoa so
like that's fun and I'm thinking about
you know you got to think about schools
all that [__] you're gonna leave
Manhattan go to Brooklyn yeah just get a
little more space I've done my Manhattan
time and I loved it but what part of
Brooklyn Fort Greene oh that's where I
went to college Joseph's College hey
Fort Greene you would not have been here
it's changed quite a bit
Jesus
um I used to move furniture and we moved
this gay couple into Fort Greene and it
was from New Jersey to Fort Greene and
they had this huge place right on the
park in Fort Greene I remember being
like Oh my God one day and I moved all
these ancient artifacts because they're
gay and they had all this cool [__] and
expensive [__] I nicked one boss this
thing was about this big from Zimbabwe
and I nicked it and this guy goes
and he just flipped out and he should
have wrapped it up what's he doing I
don't know but we moved every single
artifact I was like Indiana Jones Moving
this [__] and then I nicked one thing
and he flipped out on me brutal that's
like Mike Racine I tired Mike Racine
once to move for me to and I was moving
from my apartment I was moving from an
apartment in Brooklyn to another
apartment in Brooklyn yeah and but one
of the but then one of the couches that
I had I was going to bring to my dad's
house who was living in Staten Island so
Mike's like hire me I got it don't worry
so I'm waiting for him he calls me
because we're coming around the corner
so he comes down the block it's just him
in the moving truck I was like where's
your team I know he was like it's just
me I was like you made it seem like you
were a part of a moving organization
it's like nah it's just me it'll save
you money it'll just be me and you I'm
like I don't want to move this [__] now
you're carrying couch I don't want to do
that I would have paid more to not do it
he's like it's fine so we do it we're
going whatever drop everything off we're
on my way to my dad's we dropped stuff
in my apartment I'm not you know keeping
track of all the inventory that's his
job we got to my dad's house he opens up
the back the couch isn't in there he
left the couch at the first place I'm
like the only reason we crossed the
bridge to come is down now is to drop
off this couch he was like can I get
some money to go back I got to pay the
toll uh and I was like oh my God
but I paid him and [__] I did a
couple of those with him and he's just
got a cigarette in his mouth the entire
time he's breathing smoke in your eyes
the entire time and yeah sit in that
little that little uh front part of the
truck whatever you call it the white
window is
makes great sauce though yeah and a
great comic you know you know what the
secret is is the carrots oh really you
put just a little bit of carrots in it
don't give it away the Paisan that's all
he has it's a flaming Moe's episode hell
yeah love Mike Racine Mike's great comic
we actually just rewatched one of his
Conan sets and he's like dude he's got
so many good jokes in that set he's got
a kid now too everyone's getting
everyone's having kids that's right
that's right I want to do it I want to
do it all right yeah I think you gotta
give me a year give me a year do you
guys have like 401ks and Investments and
do stuff like that or you don't think
like that I got all that yeah I do do
you have a financial planner that
doesn't it I have a guy they were the
same guy yeah Russell yeah yeah my God
that's my guy oh yeah but but that's
your accountant
how many of our peers don't have any of
that I want to start like something are
you telling me people in entertainment
are not smart with money well I'm
thinking of the ones of us who have it
the ones of us who kind of you know not
to wear Financial experts but if any of
us can become Financial experts it'd be
a good business idea for us to create a
company where the comics invest with us
the ones who can't do it and we do it
for them and they trust them this sounds
like a horrible idea what do you think
because I don't know [__] about I know I
hire people to do it for me we if we're
involved then it goes south we're
criminals easy made up but you go you
were giving up so much money to these
financial planners one percent you're
like oh that's not a lot but it's like
it is over the course of 30 years you're
going to give them like millions of
dollars but if we can learn it ourselves
yeah well you guys both fired your
managers right yeah but then I rewired
another one oh still giving away 20 of
my money I am too and it's kicking my
ass not me I get these guys doing all my
[__] but if I say this about my manager
Emilio Savon aka the Italian woman I'll
say this he's got a ponytail yes I'll be
careful I saw this he's got a ponytail
he's going to a midlife crisis I'm not
great woman
but what he's what I like about him is
because he he has graduated you know
from being a manager and all that he's
kind of in the new world where it's not
just he's not like booking My Flights
it's not what he does it's like he's
digitally marketing me he's he's all
that stuff it doesn't matter if you call
into a radio station anymore and get on
it's fun but nobody cares it's the
digital marketing it's the Facebook it's
the Instagram it's all that and he does
all that it's the constantly on the
venues that you're going to like you
know getting your email list email he's
controlling all that so for me that's
like worth the money oh yeah but what
about the little thing because I I'm a
[__] I can't book a flight I'll [__]
it up I'll I'll drive to LaGuardia when
I'm going out of Newark I do all that
[__] he would do that too but I just for
me I'm I I those I guess since I became
a dad I just know where I'm supposed to
be always but but so you do it if you
need that yeah I just like to do it
because I like to pick my flight I like
to use my points I like to like take
some time but he would do that too okay
okay because I can't do anything that
[__] any kind of planning so I guess
Mark had his manager book his honeymoon
wedding vacations would you take a
commission yeah because I'm already
paying the guy so I'm like you want my
10 I think managers are Running Scared a
little bit I think they know that this
is kind of a dying thing these
management companies so how bad do we
really need them anymore I mean you
don't have one you're doing all right 10
years yeah yeah and you get 10 you you I
saved that and I invested in like video
stuff I pay for I I just try to put a
lot of money well I put everything back
into my you know career into the into
the shows and the road but you make a
million dollars a year you give them 10
that's 100 Grand that's a lot of [__]
money yeah that's more than Challenges
ever seen or paid for I mean it's a tax
write-off but it's still money
it's still a lot true true it's a lot of
things I think that we're all I think
because here's the thing here's the
thing as I told I I went you know I've
been trying to do my own investing now
right they have the Vanguard account
I've been trying to like watch my own
things look at my own to just be a
little I still have the money with all
these guys that we have because I'm like
trust experts you got to delegate and
Trust experts I'm all about that but I'm
like I need to start to be on the path
to try to know this stuff and understand
the stuff for my kids right oh same here
dude I'm like GameStop is due to make a
comeback I'm put I'm going on 100 I'm
going on you should do that get your
money in crypto right now
but but but one thing like because
sometimes like we don't realize I was
talking uh you know an independent you
know planner it's just a friend of mine
he has no does not I try to talk to
people now that are not incentivized to
make money off me because then you get
like the real you know set device to
make money off you they're gonna they're
very cunning yeah put your money with me
even I'll make you more of a return it's
all capitalism which I'm for because I
love this [__] country but I will say
talking to an outside Source he was
asking me he was like he showed I showed
him my gross income and then my net is
so radically different it's so much
radically lower than the gross where he
was like you know where is where is all
this money going he was like are you
overspending I was like No And I'm
showing them I have like charts and
everything he's like where is all
where's 20 of your money like every
month you're giving so much of it away I
was like that's to the manager and to
the agent and he said he was like I have
no idea about I'm not creative I have
not the slightest clue of what goes on
in the creative world he was like I am
telling you he's like I've been doing
this 25 years I am Telling You 1 000
that's a racket that is the definition
of a racket there is no there is no way
anybody figured out mathematically why
you have to give 10 to a manager and 10
agent they're just saying you have to do
it because you have to do it it's Mafia
[__] that is absolutely that's why I got
rid of him he's like you are being
ripped off there is no way that they
should be taking that much of this is
what I'm saying he said professional
athlete gets a contract they give them
what one percent two percent of the
contract maybe three percent and the
argument will be oh that's because I
only make a one-time negotiation for you
at three percent so that's why it's so
much less but I'd argue that it's like
it's the same with me you're you've
taken me in as whatever a commodity
right a commodity a talent so it's like
why do you get like so the 10 the work
that you do for me at 10 now is the same
work that you're gonna get ten percent
of when hopefully um
makes sense how long before we get
artificial intelligence as an agency oh
that's another thing I want to talk
about I'm working on it but it's coming
it's called Chris GPT
it's just a manager who went through
five years ago because they helped you
grow so maybe they deserve a little bit
of sort of I know but you get bigger and
you're still paying them 10 of the more
money you're making but you wouldn't
have gotten to this is just their side
of the argument you wouldn't have gotten
right without that right and I
understand you know and I understand
that I understand that wholeheartedly
the truth is is that's it's their
argument because they're being it
they're being positioned to say how else
am I needed unless I tell you if it
wasn't for me it wouldn't be there of
course it's the fans don't give a [__]
they pay to see Sam they don't they
don't care who you're wrapped by I think
I think you cut the manager and you
invest that 10 in analingus and
prostitutes I guess that's what you do
that's what I want to do morale High
that's what I want to do because I've
told and I've sat my children down and
told them like I need prostitutes so I
keep the relationship fresh with your
mother yeah
track
it's just a huge explosion well I have
Jazz and I have jizz my dad sat me down
when he was 16. he's like Chris the key
to success is always
do we have any do we have news yeah I
got some good ones oh
I like the shirt by the way thank you
Syracuse old school you're the one hey
you sent me an ad what side like that is
it on Paul Fredericks oh I don't know
okay PFS
I like it thank you gentlemen yeah very
old school I got a news story here
Robert De Niro that was revealed that he
has become a father for the for his
seventh child he is 79 years old can we
make the thoughts smaller what do you
think I saw that there we go that means
wow father of the seventh child at his
age what is he 70 79 years old his worst
decision since uh Meet the Fockers
he didn't like Meet the Fockers yeah I
like the first one okay oh yeah you're
right I like Meet the Parents was great
that was great I have nipples let me
take a wild guess the kid's half black
oh I love it
my friend they got divorced though is
him and his wife who was uh he found
another one for black women yeah he used
to date one of the waitresses at the
time really
for years and then he would he would
come to The Cellar like that was like
his uh wow side piece are we allowed to
say your name is that public yes
she loves white dick all right he's got
a kid now and he's I didn't know he's
79. well Jagger just had one as well and
he's got to be up there so the male
sperm can really swim ready for this
ready for this static this fact I just
learned
the last living the last living person
whose father fought in the Civil War
which was from 1861 to 1865 just died
two years ago okay so that means there
was a guy walking around two years ago
whose father fought in the Civil War
because his the father fought in the
Civil War when he was 16 he had this kid
at 90 years old he was 90 when he had
this kid and then that kid grew on to I
think the guy died when he was like 101.
wow so it's like at 90. this guy had a
kid and he had fought in the city so he
[__] someone probably 50 years younger
than him uh oh yeah yeah because the
women yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and he
fought for the South yeah
it's probably his cousin yeah
wow well you know Ari shaffir's dad was
in the Holocaust true story he's dead
that's how old Ari is right yeah so
there I mean well how old is Arya in his
50s no I'd say so no a lot of these guys
are sleeper picks man oh you think
they're young and they're like they're
they're close to 50. Wilson Vince is 68.
something crazy all right I don't know
how much Ari is in two years bro
her Chrysler is only 24.
it's crazy he's killing it yeah he looks
good yeah he looks great he's got a
trainer every day at 8am he trains he
looks very good he looks great they both
look good let's stay on track here with
the Jews yes uh an ice cream stands
don't go off yeah go get the train
great segue Matt thank you
uh an ice cream stand near Auschwitz
concentration camp causes a bit of a
controversy
um
okay
after that [__] show you need a little
pick-me-up exactly you know it's it's uh
happiness after this hell yeah we're
supposed to starve these kids too what
the hell
I like that I'm glad you said it yeah do
I have free license on this stuff oh
yeah that's I it's I mean look it's it's
far away it's not like there's a dude in
there with like a hot dogs and beer
being like get your hot dogs you know
your kosher kosher made from the real
bodies
made from the same oven yeah
I went to um Dachau in uh in uh was it
Germany concentration camp and they have
to say they had to tell us before we got
off the bus on to the you know into the
dark house do not make please do not uh
uh go on Snapchat do not do any
Instagram filters please do not take any
fun selfies yeah in front of the ovens
or on the fields because people do that
all the time and it really upsets the
locals yeah
just like yeah exactly YOLO yeah well
it's uh no I think I think the I who
cares it's ice cream right I mean I
guess people need to eat you know
hashtag genocide yeah what helps like it
helps kids learn probably right if
you're if you're like oh we've got ice
cream after something look forward to
but it's kind of a dewy move like how
can I make money off of this right hey I
don't care so ice cream just don't sell
any Bud Light
No sell it all I'd love to sell it Dylan
mccavie yeah you know I think if it's a
Jewish guy selling it it should be all
right so let them get some money out of
this yeah yeah why the hell not that's
reparations
that's a good flavor
yeah over one million Jews died at this
you know in Oshawa she's like well I'm
dying for some [__] rocky road yeah
six million flavors
there we go hey folks we might be drunk
It's brought to you by doer oh yeah
well when doer sent us over their top of
the line shorts I didn't expect them to
be this good stewart makes them makes
the most comfortable pants breathable
lightweight and durable they never go
out of style I'm wearing them right now
I feel free I feel
secure I feel frolicky and gay big fan
big fan and look summer's coming up
Summer's here I'm you walk around New
York you're walking around in a weird
dust cloud from Canada thanks a lot
Trudeau
all right if you're a doer these tough
cool shorts and pants will keep you
keep with you you're not boring don't
let your pants be and it's not only
pants doers entire menswear line of
jeans joggers shorts tees jackets are
made to look sharp while keeping up with
your busy lifestyle
made from materials like wood chips
plants and recycled plastic bottles doer
has finally made sustainable clothing
that's long lasting and stylish I feel
good I look good I smell terrible trust
me you need to add doer to your summer
wardrobe check out doers Flagship stores
in La and Denver or shop online at
shopdoer a that's
s-h-o-p-d-u-e-r.com our listeners get 15
off site-wide using Code drunk that's
pretty good for 15 off your order go to
shopdoer.com
s-h-o-p-d-u-e-r.com and use special
promo code drunk get on it folks thank
you
it's time to break out the beach balls
it's smooth sack summer boys and that
means manscaped is here to make sure
you're ready look good on the boardwalk
or the Waverunner from the Backyard BBQ
to the yacht club manscapes performance
package will get you there the lawnmower
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer with its LED
spotlight and the 7000 RPM Motor takes
care of you below that means your ball
bag well the weed whacker 2.0 ear and
nose hair trimmer for the older fellas
takes care of above
yeah I've used this before I trim my
balls if I have a woman going down they
want to make sure it's not too hairy I
want to make sure that it's uh groomed
uh I put a little Jewish star of David
in there with the trimmer I think it
works nicely it fights anti-Semitism get
20 off it and free shipping with code
drunk at manscape.com there's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com use
the code uh drunk smooth sack summer get
on board or get left behind get 20 off
at manscape.com with promo code drunk
here here here's another news story Iowa
couple charged with leaving their child
behind to take a trip to Kansas City wow
how bad is Iowa
you need to live it up in KC yeah oh I
mean that's yes where do they leave the
child like all like a home alone
situation alone situation yeah this is
real life home alone though you don't
you don't have this you have you know a
kid wandering professional yeah do you
how old was the kid I'm checking here
he's young I think by the way what's his
[__] last name Matt
also I think they're dressed the same
let's see
Chansey Mariah raylen and oh that's
that's a lot of kids Buford no no
there's another name in there oh Jacob
Morrell 30 years old
he smells it differently though he's not
a real Jew
yeah that's not that's not a drug of
choice usually but uh yeah they left the
kid on like a seven-year-old seven wow
seven is it's illegal I'm trying to
think I have a seven-year-old daughter
she would um if I left her alone for a
day I think she'd survive this kid
survived right yeah but yeah you can't
yeah but but yeah no no yeah I don't
know Age kid could you leave on the
streets of Manhattan and like they could
live
yeah a day or two do they have the
apartment or on the street they're on
the street well Manhattan is much easier
than being abandoned on a highway here
although I'm looking at their mug shots
I think this kid might be better off I
don't know yeah true the guy's not bad
looking at all yeah the lady's
terrifying but yeah now wait they didn't
leave them in the home
they literally left them on the street
yeah yeah that's crazy why did they do
it were they in like a drunken a
drug-fueled stupor I think Kansas City
is just that good yeah they wanted their
barbecue right
damn that is rough what can you do [__]
that kid
they're better off I mean those these
kids will go to a foster home if I was
if I was at foster care and I took in
that kid first thing I do taking an
Auschwitz get some ice cream
get on the flight yeah
it's the barbecue ain't the only thing
slow and uh yeah right by the way sounds
like a concentration camp take you to
Haagen-Dazs
[Laughter]
van Lewin a lot of German Briars I don't
think van Leon's German but it sounds it
it's got the van yeah kids love a van
yeah all right so cow and Poland escaped
a slaughterhouse and swam across the
river to an island where it remained for
weeks the cow became a symbol of freedom
and was eventually pardoned by the
president of Poland then they ate him
the cow now named saved lives out his
days in a Farm Sanctuary what is this
Cool Hand Luke what the hell is going on
I know right I think no cows could swim
yeah me neither interesting the udder
helps you float
maybe yeah yeah under Madness oh there
we go
oh my God look at the Black Cow
okay there it is glip it they're not
good swimmers though that doesn't look
they were hanging in there they're
hanging in but
I don't know is it so he gets to live
but then he has to watch all his friends
get turned into a Big Mac right here
that's a weird existence so like you're
safe every other cow is dead but I watch
the documentary I think it's something
about fish is it sea spiricy one of
those yeah the fish are disgusting like
I thought you're eating fish or eating a
cleaner meat a wild salmon it's all lies
like salmon is not so that's salmon that
we eat that's pink that's not it's
actual color at all like it's not
supposed to be no if you look at it like
the show the videos they have like
rashes all over them and blisters
because of like the contamination of
like the water it's fish is worse for
you even wild fish than red meat they
say because of all the toxic really
which you don't know yeah I I they like
I was getting these omega-3 fish oil
pills from Nordic Naturals which is um
like they're I thought like oh it's
Nordic it's the Vikings it's free fish
but they're like it's all fish farm so
it's like loaded with chemicals where
you should be getting your Omega-3s from
algae from because the fish eat the
algae and that's where they get the
cardiovascular benefits so if you just
like go to the source and eat the algae
pills that supposedly that's better than
fish oil that's better there's a new fat
every three years they say was good they
would say a fish oil was good for you
know add and it gave you health benefits
right but now they're saying that
because of all that was true but now
because of all the you know chemicals in
these fish farms and over production of
fish and oh it's going to get to the
point where like the fish and most of
the food we eat is all going to have to
be genetically made in a in a lab it's
just gonna have to be because the wild
animals we've polluted the Earth so much
that it's it the only way to do it is to
now just home just make like the chicken
from KFC is some of the healthiest
chicken you can eat because it's
genetically made in a lab wow so it's
like it removes I know dude I've seen
the people who eat it they don't want
that house I know well no fried chicken
is bad but it's like the healthiest type
of fried chicken right that makes sense
but it's so funny that the people who
are like so anti vegan are going to be
eating food that's prepped similar to
how vegans yeah because if it's made in
the lab and it's you know altered it's
just where we're going it's it was it
was wild and like look at so many people
that you have to keep pumping in these
drugs to these animals to make them grow
and get bigger and bigger because we
need to feed everybody right so yeah
they're full of drugs and contaminants
so you're right I think the lab should
be cleaner yeah we've depleted something
like we've depleted something like 80
percent of the fish Source fish sources
in the Atlantic Ocean are gone already
from like from just like 100 years
damn yeah it's wild dude we really will
ruin some [__]
man I ate a bunch of crawfish the other
day and I just think of Norman every
time I eat it it's like no I was in
Texas but that's like Mark's favorite
food big old bag in uh last week in New
Orleans just eat it right out of a bag
crack it open that crawfish ravioli once
it was awesome oh really very nice you
could put anything in ravioli true yeah
you can put anything Viking [__]
whatever Auschwitz ice cream
I love ravioli ravioli tortellini I'm a
big cheese filled pasta guy yeah no it's
the best yeah I mean it's just cheese
and pasta I think Italian food's the
best food and I really don't think it's
like when people try to debate it they
just it's like just shut up
I mean I love it I mean it's just it's
all noodles it's a different shape and
then a sauce Mexican food right you can
go to an Italian restaurant and you
could just pretty pretty much know that
at least something on the menus you're
gonna oh that's true that's true you
can't go wrong I just feel like Italian
is safe like I feel like you can't
really bring anyone out although these
days who knows people have like weird
gluten [__] and this car a lot of carbs
yeah I want the food in Sicily everyone
talks about how the food in Italy and
Sicily is like amazing and mind-blowing
and maybe it's because I went in there
with like this notion of like this
food's gonna be great but like every
other meal was like not that good yeah
there was like a couple of dishes that I
had like this is the best pizza or best
pasta I've ever had in my life but then
every other dish was like this is like
fine right and I think that we have so
much preservatives and salt and stuff in
our food that it's like America we just
have the best food like they don't have
the [__] in Italy this size they just
don't have it no you can find it but
it's like in the tourist parts for
Americans like they would never eat this
and I'm like you know yeah that's how
you have to live so you don't have this
size in Italy no you can't you can't
even attempt to buy clothes in Italy
like I'm I went to um in h m in Palermo
Sicily just like killing time walked
around and I my size waist is a 36 and I
put on what a 36 is there and it was
like I couldn't even get my thigh it
could they wouldn't come past my
thoughts and I was like what size would
I be here like a 44 and they're like oh
we only have up to 38 Prego
your next special size 40 waist yeah I
got too much Prego that's what they say
but that's like you know something about
like New York food people say like New
York to like you know New Haven is the
best pizza but I feel like New York is
so consistent like very good we're gonna
have the best food but we're just so
consistent can't go wrong yep yeah I
mean like I you just walk into this
random Bakery and there's not even a
line and it's some of the best Suites
you've ever had where it's like there
would only be one of these in another
city and it'd be like a two hour wait to
get in but it's just like any Pizzeria
you walk into New York will like blow
somebody's Minds from another city well
there's so much competition you got to
be good or you're gone that's it but the
Gomez told me he went to Italy ate pasta
and pizza every day lost weight because
they have so much less preservatives
and you walk yeah that's what I did I
drank wine ate pasta and pizza every day
went off my sweets roll went off my
intermittent fasting and I gained well
I'd stayed the exact same way isn't that
weird and they drink wine and smoke
cigarettes no headaches with the wine
either I did not get one headache from
drinking wine because they don't have
the sulfates in them yeah it's organic
or is it well we have to put sulfates
and preservatives and even when we
import the wine but there they don't
have to the sulfates are really I think
give you the hangover yeah really well
remember when we would drink that
natural wine and we never got hangovers
no no no problem at all no but then the
wine snobs here will trash the broccoli
stuff yeah they're like they're like oh
that's [__] gone I gotta try this
these wine guys don't know anything I
think if you put two different things in
front of them they couldn't tell they're
putting their nose in there they're Oaky
it's Berry [__] out of here they must
know something you've given your life to
it you've got to know something I don't
know I'd like to see a blind taste test
you ever seen a Suave shampoo they put
it in all these different bottles and
they asked everybody what's the
difference was it scientists and they're
all like it's all the same really yeah
Suave and perp plus and uh organic
whatever [__] it's all the same yeah
people just follow they just have these
political talking points and then when
you ask them one final question they're
like what I saw this video of this
college kid this girl she was like I'm
sick and tired of straight white men
getting things that were designed for us
and they're taking things that we
deserve and blah blah blah blah blah and
then the interviewer was like what's one
thing that the straight straight white
man has gotten from this University that
you haven't gotten and she was like I
have to go to class
video and I'm like yeah I get it it's
like he took he took that YouTube video
and got a lot of hits yeah yeah
I was just like you know yeah if you're
gonna [__] protest something just
just have reasons why you're dealing do
the research don't just do it because
everybody else is doing it part of being
young is having that angst and not
knowing what no knowing why I feel like
sure this person was 45 going back to
school and now it's all over the
Internet before it was like annoying
young people were annoying and you go
all right whatever and you move on but
now it's like in your face on Tick Tock
it must be embarrassing you know being
young and having this weird record of
just doing dumb [__] do you see Dina
Dina what she posted oh it was great you
know she got kind of canceled or
whatever for making that rapper joke
yeah years ago and like death threats
and I'm gonna come to your house it was
crazy
she got doxed it's crazy people actually
showed up to her house I don't know
about that but she she flipped out she
was really scared and [__] her up or
whatever so she posted the other day
where is it uh she showed the the direct
message it's on her stories it might be
gone by now but she joked to the direct
message and it was like I'm gonna kill
you [__] you talk like that about a
rapper I'm gonna come to your house and
slit your throat and then that was 2018.
you can see the date one message later I
can't believe I was this cringe sorry
and you're like whoa people can change
people can wake up later a couple years
later they were like geez you know what
still [__] that guy yeah still like like
great that you had some growth but like
you're writing to someone you're gonna
slit their throat yeah [__] I got a
thousand of those that's the truth there
there is truth to that what Sam's saying
too because I think about that a lot as
well I'm like you know yes so and so
we're all different whatever but it's
like I was 18 once I've been through
totally I never told every anyone I want
to Slit their throat of course do this I
wasn't dming women violent threats yeah
like I think I think progress is good
but also like I'm not gonna say
celebrate his [__] uh growth I'm not
saying he's a hero but I think it's a
good sign that people can come back to
earth and wake up a little but no I
agree this guy's a piece of [__] we want
to be in a society of forgiveness I
agree with that but it's like for me
it's like sometimes if the person has
that in you then you have that in you
like you know like if you have it in you
have it in you and yes you've grown
apology accepted fine but it's also like
stay over there don't ever come in my
space again yes it's like you know
you're evil you got evil yeah you have
it in you so it's like I don't want to
be near that yeah right now there's this
uh what do you call the southern baptist
the gay hating godhead convention no no
the guys
Tony DeStefano the Westbrook
the Westborough people they're all like
you know go to gay funerals and pro that
good you're going to hell gay guy your
gay son sucks whatever you're all going
to hell and then a lot of them now have
come to light and be like oh [__] that
was crazy sorry about that and I think
that's good you know as much as I hate
those people and they're they're
ignorant and oh yeah stupid no it is
better than just them staying like that
yeah forgiving someone in my opinion
like you forgive them and whatever but
that doesn't mean I have you have to be
in my life every day I can forgive you
and move on good point but it's like we
don't have to be friends yeah I think
Dina should hang out with that guy he
seems cool yeah I pay good money to
watch that I get so angry dude I get
like I left the uh I left the doctor and
uh oh my God you know what [__]
happened to me
this may be a bit here but this happened
to me I was leaving the uh doctor
yesterday they [__] up my appointment
like I I took it down very
no way it was my fault I was like you
took it I sound fun a date right now uh
there's no way this was my fault no they
gave me the they took down the wrong
date I so I go in though like the no
there's your phone I said no it's not I
took this down correctly yeah and the
woman starts laughing at my face and I
was like you know my neck's in pain
you're laughing at a person in the
hospital and she just goes she goes I'm
sorry oh but I still was angry I'm like
what do I do with this anger that's big
of her though I know that's big of her
to say sorry I know no I appreciated
that now you gotta punch something
because you gotta get it out somewhere
yeah like can I still hit you in the
face real quick right she's like all
right yeah no I uh oh sorry I was
walking my dog yesterday on my block and
a car pulled up and the window rolled
down and this woman just dropped a can
of Coke out the window I hate that and
I'm like right in line with her so I'm
eyeballing I'm walking dog and she hits
me with I litter
[Laughter]
there's acceptance and the honesty of it
yeah yeah anyway well I was telling my
mom this whole thing that happened
afterwards you know I'm on the phone
with my mom and I'm complaining about
because it took her a while to apologize
she didn't just say I'm sorry I was like
you know this is really rude and I kept
my cool but you know I wanted to call it
apologize GED
but I'm telling my mom this [__] and my
mom I go what a trash bag of a human mom
goes where did you learn to speak like
this I don't speak like this and I'm
thinking like maybe the angle for the
bit could be like yeah men my age don't
learn to speak from their mother you
think guys are just having
confrontations and as I'm walking out
I'm like I have never
every day yeah yeah how dare you I'm
gonna write a letter
I'm gonna get your father
that's a funny book maybe there's a bit
definitely a bit yeah yeah I don't know
I didn't teach you to speak like this
yeah yeah I also know a lot of dirty
talk he didn't teach me that either lady
no they put the needle I got the like I
went today I got the neck injection and
it's like it's so weird having to leave
uh because I'm like hey you guys hurry
up I'm there for a while I'm like hurry
up I've got to be somewhere I gotta be
the work thing and they're like oh you
have a work thing and I'm like I have to
get drunk in the afternoon please
podcast yeah
but uh no man but she did apologize to
that she apologized I I did appreciate
that and I saw her again today and there
was like a nod I didn't it was you know
there was no listen people acknowledge
they mess up that's fine I think I think
it's a yeah when the people who like
they get so insecure about their [__] up
that they just like well now I'm gonna
just yeah because it's like there's a
dishonesty there yes but being honest
about it it's like you know it's like um
in the Revolutionary War Major John
Andre he got he was British and he got
um caught spying for the British and
because he was a major they said George
Washington said well you know you're a
major so you spied though and he was
like listen I spied I know I spied you
guys caught me I'm not even trying to
deny this I'm a spy and because of that
they were like look the penalty for this
is firing squad that's what happened but
since you're the major and you were
honest we're gonna let you hang yourself
well you can hang so we have to kill you
one way or another they have the public
you have to get executed wow but they
let him like choose his own execution
because uh it's like the worst version
of the prices right yeah
you either get firing squad or you eat
Viking [__] ravioli yeah so what did he
do he hung himself
is this from the David McCullough book
I'm sure they mentioned it but I just
know that this is actually I actually
learned about Major John Andre from the
show called Turn it was about the
Washington uh George Washington spiring
Culpepper sparring very interesting but
they what they do is for him for him
what they did is rather than just
letting him hang there and like let his
eyes bulge out of his head they hung
they brought his you know they wrapped
The Noose around his neck and then they
brought him up to like the next Branch
up and they just let him drop so he
broke his neck it's an instant death
that's better better it's about be
honest kids don't spy I guess that might
help your neck
I feel a lot better right now after this
injection well they reject you with
cortisone no it wasn't cortisone I
couldn't be drinking most cortisone it
was some sort yeah you can I mean I have
yeah you're not supposed to yeah
um no but I'm glad it's uh yeah because
that next [__] having like a
debilitating injury like that it just
makes you feel like it reminds you to be
grateful when you're not yes because a
lot of times we're only you know remind
find it reminded of uh you know being
grateful when we're in pain or really
sick but it's like you got to think
about it every day so true got to be
grateful every day because the net goes
out you have a bad night's sleep and
you're like oh this sucks
it sucks and I'm like trying to exercise
through it all the time but I'm just in
pain it sucks yeah we also you want to
be that dude who's like complaining all
the time and right I already complain
all the time a comic it's like you know
yeah I know
how about those only fence twins
we were talking about the mall trip uh
the guys who I was with I've been
potting all day I've been seeing this uh
you got ahead of my twins uh no they
were in the crowd and they were like
pretty hot only fans Twins and uh it's
hilarious we're all jerking off to Sam
Morris Instagram and I literally uh and
literally
um a girl I'm seeing is like did you uh
did you sleep with them and I was like I
spent the night with you what are you
talking about yeah she's like I'll ask
you again
they were really smoking hot oh really
do they show themselves dude you should
have thrown up there they should have uh
thrown up their only fans someone tagged
them someone in the in my comments
tagged them can we get I think they're
pretty popular a big screen here there
we go look at these twins and then of
course there was like an only Fan's
guide there too with his girl I just
show [__] was that the Crest theater was
it no that was the Balboa
is beautiful I love San Diego San Diego
is one of the best beautiful women Diego
nice Republican gem it is red it's like
it's in the man it's like purple yeah
it's purple yeah but uh it no San Diego
is a great comedy crowd great crowds
that club that American Comedy Company
there was always cool because uh they'd
give you weed and Edibles and stuff
right in the green room I couldn't work
there because he called my agent the
seaward and all caps and that that cost
that cost a lot of clients work and then
he would like always offer way more
money than with The Comedy Store offered
but I was like I guess we're gonna go
with the one that didn't call her the
sea you kind of like you almost hope the
other club was like can you call her
[__] too this one is more money yeah but
now we got berkwood so he's like call me
a [__] all day yeah I like it he turns
me on the club just explodes what the
hell Berk's upset if you don't call him
a contest what the [__] I thought we
were doing a good deal here you're
supposed to tell me you want to kill me
and my family it's so funny Chris and I
have this like power agent but then he's
just at the Knicks game the other night
and he's just texts me me and he's just
like I'm so sad like it's so weird to
see a guy wow who you just used to be
like [__] you give me the best deal and
you're like yeah and then he's just like
I'm not I'm not happy
he's just like one of us yeah yeah he's
like I know he was like he was like it's
so beautiful to see the way you are with
your daughters sometimes I want to feel
like that I'm like no you don't you need
to be a [__] hard ass [__]
don't go soft on me yes yes
you're rooting against them having a
life at all yeah no I'm like I want you
to get a vasectomy now
you're always available it's great I
want you to be mad
he reps like Bill Burr and Kevin Hart
and he still gets back to like all our
attacks because it doesn't stop working
wow it's pretty awesome yeah good for
him yeah that's what you want I'm
waiting I remember one time I had an
agent who accidentally sent me I think
it was like JB smooves offer and it was
like something this was like a few years
ago it was like he sent me he's like hey
got the money up you're gonna be making
you know a hundred grand for this thing
and I was like oh my God
yes and I told my family like you know
like it was like that um from a Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air when the butler thinks
he won the lottery and it's like telling
everyone [__] you [__] you and then he
was like sorry man that was for JB
Smoove yeah he was like you're a 1500
for Cap City
no he's a really cool guy jbj great guy
I barely know it could be nicer the
couple times I met him he was like the
nicest dude I did Jim and Sam with it
once I don't know what he said you
talked the whole time I didn't
understand any of it but then he took
photos with us after he was super nice
great Beast movie one time one of the
first opportunities I ever got like in
you know when I was like just doing
comedy as a full-time job was I got to
be in a Nike commercial for Carmelo
Anthony's when he was on the Knicks like
his new sneakers yeah and JB Smoove was
like the lead guy and I was like
somebody on the train that like would
talk to him or whatever yeah yeah Chris
Stefano Carmelo Anthony JB smooth Nike
commercial I don't know and I know you
did this yeah it was like it was like
2013 and wow and and just what was it
for it was for Carmelo Anthony's like
sneaker like Nike Nike sneaker was it
had to be Nike yeah I think is this it
Jordan stay mellow this was it stay
mellow so the this is the fortune teller
one yeah that's me and him oh look at
that we did one yeah and then we did one
on a train so you got to meet mellow too
no mellow didn't come yeah
wow watching you're great with him right
with him
yeah I I just I was doing comedy like
whatever two years someone made a
hundred thousand dollars for this it's
great yes yep and so
those are pretty cool shoes
they were good they were comfortable
did they give you a pair yeah not only
did they give me a pair they gave
they gave me a pair of The Carmelos and
then they gave me 10 because it's all
with Jordan they gave me 10 pairs of
Jordans like from like like the ones the
twos that they get uh the fives they
gave me Delaney's they gave me all these
different types of Jordans in there my
daughter had just born uh no that wasn't
it um I got in with Nike in a way and
then when my daughter was born a couple
years later they sent her like 10 pairs
of Jordans with Nike sweat set Jordan
sweat sets for like each year like I
still have Jordans and they went all the
way up to size 10 for like they were so
cool but then I don't know what happened
I lost contact with them but anyway
watching Carmella watching JB's move
interact on a set and keep it funny the
whole time and learn everybody bro yeah
I was like oh [__] like that's how you
do it watching him I was like oh okay so
he's humongous star and he acts this way
so it's like don't ever you know think
that you're bigger than you are because
I saw a guy at his level be so kind and
down to earth and cool I was like the
ones who you see or hear about are just
like dicks to everybody I think they're
just really like insecure and like they
don't want to be bigger than they are
exactly because the ones who are
confident don't act that way every time
every story you read about Nicholson on
set back in the day he was like the
coolest dude yeah he was awesome at
everybody and you're like yeah that's
what you [__] do yeah but that
shouldn't even be celebrated like that's
how it should be we've all had that uh
that oh that headliner that you open for
who is super mean you're like but I
don't even respect you
you're bombing every night you're a hack
you have a puppet yeah you hear that
Dunham
no did you ever work with him I never he
seemed like a nice guy yeah Jeff Dunham
he's a zillionaire oh my god dude he
sells out like Arenas like we sell out
like one night or so yeah exactly yeah
like it's just like he's I was doing
Dallas I was doing the House of Blues or
something in Dallas a few months ago and
he was doing the arena yeah people at
Vermont for his show at my hotel and I
was going down the elevator and one of
like the kids that was with his family
like recognized me he's like oh you're
here I was like yo you guys come in the
show they're like now we're going to see
Jeff Dunham yeah I was like oh man but
then but then when my show I realized my
show ended at like 8 30 I always do
seven o'clock shows his only started at
eight I was like I want to get in yeah I
want to see him but I couldn't get in oh
that's my Jeff Dunham alarm
it's interesting that you did that ad
with Melo and JB I mean that's it's so
amazing these athletes just get paid
they don't even have to show up they're
just I know using like a clip of him
with a basketball no I'll tell you I'll
be honest this was 2013. I had no money
had just started but I I me I had
nothing two lines in that they gave me
one hundred thousand dollars wow one
hundred thousand dollars of life I
couldn't believe it like I remember I
was crying my dad was like because that
was like the first time I ever made
anything yeah you know and so I was like
holy [__] so I was thinking even back
then if I got a hundred thousand dollars
I'm like nothing well you have a shoe
deal what did JB get what did Carmelo
get we know you see these ads now where
it's like Kevin Hart and and Iverson and
Steph Curry and it's like it looks like
they're all photoshopped in it looks
like they didn't even all do it they're
all so busy that I think they they just
used uh CGI or whatever I'm sure they
did and just for that like I don't think
Kevin Hart's going on to your set for
something like a Chase commercial or
whatever for you have to give them like
a million dollars easily easily
are they together there's no way they're
together why not
they're probably all too busy yeah but
they do look a little fuzzy that's what
I'm saying
I bet Kevin was there in the res weren't
because he's got a visa thing he's got
like a Chase contract I think
interesting that could be the future
just CGI why do we need uh Chris D right
we'll just we'll just put a little image
up of Christy that's it why not get in
his ass oh I know who I think is gay
Mitchell Robinson who's that Mitchell
Robinson I think it's possible it'd be
awesome if it'd be awesome
gay star yeah I bet I can tell by the
way Mitchell Robinson gay I think he is
oh super gay
that's a wrap
hey man
he might just have a lisp I don't know
if he's definitely Matteo pops up from
underneath the thing
we love Mash I thought yeah I could see
it he was I love Mitchell Robinson it'd
be great to have like an actual like
Superstar especially in New York okay we
need it who is it
that might be a nice tactic right now
like you're a bubble player or whatever
you're looking for a max deal you come
out of the closet you're getting it
be gay for the deal that's my new
reality show that I'm pitching take it
to the butthole pay for the deal take it
to the bottle hey everybody the news
stories that we've collect our small we
touch them all
yeah oh we got another one
a man in Pennsylvania was arrested for
attempting to mail a live snake the man
attacked the snake into a box and
attempted to ship it to another state
the package was discovered by a postal
worker uh who contacted authorities a
man was charged with recklessly
endangering another person now was that
really a dildo and he was like it's a
snake just jumping a snake I read this
one he actually it was to his
ex-girlfriend oh yeah he was trying to
kill her yeah I mean but that's like can
you imagine you get a package from your
action you're like finally I got my
shoes back and right a live snake wow
he's like a stalker he's a creep yeah
yeah
damn you mail stuff back after a breakup
no no I I mean
for me it's like if we break up you know
I just I anything that you want there's
nothing that I really need or care about
that much that I would need to get back
no I mean do you send it to her though
oh um
I usually cut my losses too I don't I
don't answer [__] I just don't know no
no keep the kids
I don't know that's a good question good
question probably is hard I broke up
with this girl and uh we lived together
she was like I'm coming to take all my
stuff I was like no problem she had the
key I was like I won't be there I took
the [__] soap she bought me like half
used bar of soap wow that's pretty yeah
she was mad I I really liked these
purple chairs that I had I had these
purple like upholstered chairs and when
I moved out she got to keep the chairs
and then I swear to Christ like a month
later maybe three weeks later
I would like walk past like the old
apartment just to like you know smell
her whatever I was going through and the
chairs were out on the side of the by
the fire hydrant for a garbage
collection come on the [__] chairs
yeah and they're all [__] up and had
all marks on them and stuff so it's like
a camera I was like [__] I didn't think
the ass eating was gay but the purple
you ruined my furniture yeah yeah I'm
gonna say right now I'm dating Mitchell
Robinson
I had an X once mail me back I didn't
ask for it but she mailed me back a
Julius Randle Jersey that I had and
after this playoffs I'm like you could
have kept it yeah as a matter of fact
you're the reason why he's playing
something
but now I'm trying to think this it's
probably like sports related [__] that I
left there that you care about yeah I
don't yeah I'm just I don't really but
it's a passive aggressive move sometimes
to mail it back of course it's a message
it's a horse head sometimes it's them
being nice like hey I miss you here I'm
sorry here's your stuff but sometimes
it's just like no note here
good riddance for my life yeah I never
bring [__] over that's my move really I
keep it very separate segregation I like
it I believe in it no but yeah I don't
bring anything over there and when I
break up with them I take it myself I
don't want to have to get any mailed or
come back over I don't want to see them
again like you like to be where it's
done it's done it's separate that's it
we're never talking to each other or
seeing each other again totally usually
don't want the [__] back I'm just like
keep it even if it's like you know maybe
it was like sneakers or something it's
like the worst thing I lost yeah it's
like if you can buy new sneakers yeah
they were never like like really
expensive or anything tell you what you
can't get the Carmelo Anthony
and I think about something doing my
commercial you got paid so [__] it now
you know a lot about history yes I love
history you're a buff I'm a buff baby
well I'm not a buff I'm not uh but I
like certain parts of History I like to
learn about it because I kind of feel
like when you start to delve into
history you realize
there's really no new problems yeah
there's just new leaders there's new
technology but the problems and the
human the way the human mind works it's
been exactly the same since the
beginning of time yeah human nature
nothing's new man history repeats itself
and it can be comforting right yeah
he's offended
he's gonna pick it oh what a good dad I
love it um well she was my idea but it
does help it's like it gives you comfort
there like this [__] has all happened
before it really yeah yeah and it's like
cold cold war with Russia been there
yeah we have good vaccine stuff really
oh yeah Benjamin Franklin was one of the
first proponents to be like get they
would call it inoculation back then not
vaccination but it's like get inoculated
because his son died of
um typhoid tuberculosis it was something
uh was a time for it his son died of
what they thought at that time to be a
preventable disease a lot of times
people would get leeches you would get I
think it would it might have been
typhoid where you would get you had it I
would put a leech on you suck your blood
out infected blood give myself a little
bit of it just enough to make me sick to
build up the antibodies to to beat it
and that and it was very controversial
back then the same protests that were
going on the same exact thing except it
was about leeches and inoculation not
about Covenant vaccination interesting
and you had people for it people against
it the government getting involved the
same exact thing just different
Technologies and different mouthpieces
but the problem is now we have a
megaphone before you were just like that
I hate the inoculation guy on his porch
you know it was only a few people yeah
right yeah now it's just like ah it's
all over viral this and that everybody
has an opinion yeah that that is a that
is an issue but it's a new Factor
honestly I think the way to solve that
too is is like for me like I'm on social
media I don't even run my own social
media anymore I'm on social media so
infrequently because I'm like you made
that decision no the cancer of it so
what happened was it is evil is really
so I lost like 40 pounds and got off so
and and got off social media at the
beginning of the weight loss and the
intermittent fasting and the social
media coincided with each other it was
last August where I was like I hate the
way I feel in my body and I hate the way
my mind is so I was like I sat down for
like hours one day and I was like how do
you [__] fix this like you know I I'm
always worried you know I'm still always
worried about my kids my family but I
was like take a step away from them just
for a few hours go sit in a park which I
did Shout Out Fort Wadsworth Park Staten
Island sat there and was it was a
British stronghold during the
Revolutionary War but then we beat we
got it back it's where Americans
yep and and so I said figure this out
and the way I came to I said I had seen
I was on social media scrolling like
mindlessly not thinking and I saw uh
Elon Musk had tweeted this is not an ad
this is not a plug I lost a lot of
weight using this app called zero
fasting app intermittent fasting and I
was like that I feel like that's a sign
I said take this guy's advice take it
and then so the Mindless scrolling that
you're doing that's stopping tomorrow
Doom scrolling yeah so I did that and I
was like and and it and I don't think
that I've been able to continue My
fasting and my weight loss stuff and my
like staying focused on what I need to
do in my career if I was still on social
media wow because I didn't realize
subconsciously every day I was comparing
myself to somebody else or comparing my
life to somebody else's life that was
all manufactured anyway and then when I
got rid of that and I started only
thinking about me and my life and me and
my world I was like I'm happy I have
what I want yeah so what if I'm not
selling as many tickets as so and so or
so what if this guy's more jacked than I
am it doesn't matter and I don't see it
every day if I see it I see it if I hear
now when if I hear about a friend doing
well I'm just genuinely happy for them
as opposed to comparing myself to them
at nauseam all day every day so I'm
doing great but you can't take that in
because you're comparing I have a
similar problem where I can't feel like
the good A lot of the time it's just
it's it's tough It's like I'll be bummed
at one venue who's not selling to my
agent will be like this is like a very
good dude but that's okay because at
least it's I mean it's you know we want
to be happy all the time but it's like
at least you're only comparing yourself
to yourself what happened to me was I
would be in a city and be like oh I sold
out uh Baltimore and then you know
because of Geo tracking and tagging and
all that because of these algorithms I
would then see an ad for you know you
guys are doing Baltimore next week and
you have two shows sold out so then it
would automatically make my win feel
like a loss when it's not a loss it's
just there's so much goes into that
though right maybe like you know we all
tour so much maybe you just played a
city that was close to it right maybe of
course it wasn't spaced out oh yeah no
no there's all logical reasons why but
for me it's like the you know like Teddy
Roosevelt says comparison is the thief
of joy and I was like that's all I do
all all social media is to me is a
comparison yes compare and you will
despair that's it for us it's you know
it's it's a it's a networking tool and
it's a publicity tool it's a marketing
tool to sell our tickets so I'm fine
with that but I don't have anything to
do with it I give you know the guy who
runs at the content I approve the Flyers
and then he posts it because that's all
I'm using it for if you're doing it for
anything else then we're either
comparing yourself to others or you're
comparing your you to you at a at a time
in your past and then what's going to
start to happen is you're going to
forget that six months ago you took that
perfectly crafted picture of yourself
with the right lighting and you're like
man I gotta look like that guy again but
you actually look better than that guy
but you forgot that that image of that
guy was just perfectly crafted and not
real so I don't even compare me to me I
only compare me to like present day me
yeah was I better yesterday was I you
know am I trying to get a little bit
better than yesterday that's okay but
when you're talking about me from a year
ago I'm like I don't know so many things
have happened since then we forget that
yeah and then also not taking in
the social media comments yes the
negative is everybody knows about the
negative of how much it hurts no matter
what but the positive too the positive
will throw your ego off the positive
will make you kind of you know you'll
get like this kind of version of
yourself that like you have no balance
and you're like oh these people are
saying I'm awesome so I must be or these
people saying are suck I must be when
it's like really like both are probably
true yeah right so you stay in the
middle and I think it's all okay yeah
you know and and I just think like and
you got to compare yourself to what you
wanted to be if you could see yourself
now from 2010 or 2011 you'd be like what
the [__] can I complain about think
about any of us sitting at Caroline's
March Madness thing that we did in 2012
if any of us had the careers we have now
we'd be like we would never complain oh
but yeah it's 10 years later and all we
do is complain all we do is go away
I complain about little dumb things
that's like I'm I'm just irritable it's
not to speak about the Chinese
but uh no I I'm I'm happy I'm pretty
happy you know I hope so I hope you can
absorb and take it in because all of us
what we've done is well I think you just
fought with the doctor today yeah that's
a little thing you fought with the neck
doctor
no I uh I get cranky but I'm like happy
genuinely little moment threw me off but
they don't throw me out well listen but
that's the thing like what what I'm
saying about me and social media and My
fasting it works for me because I needed
to do that but you may not need to do
that it's like some of us like we're
here having a casual drink and it's fine
but some of our peers if they did that
they'd be dead in a week yeah you know
so it's like whatever work you got to
find what works for you I think that's
what this game of life is it's like yes
what works for you you got to have
discipline too because my lady's
obsessed with Tick Tock and she'll just
she won't get her eyes off it we'll put
a movie on she can't stop we're at a
restaurant I have to take her phone away
from her and then she'll delete tick
tock because she's like it's ruining my
life and I'm like great good for you two
days later back on the phone I'm like
whatever she's like I got Tick Tock
again and I'm like she'll find a reason
yeah it's so sophisticated what they do
they hook you in I mean they literally
take the [__] you look at the most
that's the type of stuff they feed you
you know what I get a lot here's the
tick tock peeve
is a TTP a TTP the people who are
cooking but just like on their counter
uh they're making nachos but they're
just like throwing everything out
they're not using a tray it's just like
chips sour cream cheese it's like I'm
like that's your table these Super Cuts
yeah a mouse ran across that thing an
hour ago they don't care yeah yeah but
she loves that [__] I hate it all over
there I mean look I watched but I mean
that's why I mean clearly on some level
I'm into this cooking stuff yeah they're
like food stuff but right I know but I
think I think it is bad and it consumes
so much of our brain space like I think
I write less jokes and have less ideas
because of the internet you're not
giving yourself that moment to just be
like isolated yeah we used to have that
moment so much more where you were just
kind of like be Louie used to call it
like being in the abyss yeah that's a
great thing anyone said to me it's like
put the put the [__] phone down and
be in the abyss you know that's what
does he mean by that like just just in
the isolation alone like feel the same
and that's when the thoughts will come
in he's right he's completely right I
mean he he did a bit on panel once great
like his he's like doesn't want his kids
to have a phone because you get to just
look at the phone and not feel sad he's
like but feeling sad is a part of being
a human and you got to learn to deal
with that or else you'll never be able
to deal with it right I do think it's
good for creativity to to not have a
crutch to just leave yes yes because
sometimes those low moments is when
something really funny hits you like you
know I was cranky about the doctor I'm
like well maybe that's a joke but I just
you know what I mean like you have those
things where you're like yeah if I just
looked at my phone and was like I'm
cranky you don't you have to just like
let yourself feel totally I know my mom
and it goes away and you're good my mom
told me one time oh you know call her
whatever like every other day and you
know it's like after months and months
and months of like oh he's calling her
she was like you're always calling me
like when you're driving alone and I was
like yeah I mean like I'm bored I want
to just be in the car alone driving to
wherever she was like but you should be
she was like you feel like you're you're
making up reasons to call people because
you don't want to be alone she was like
but you should just practice being alone
if you and if and it's a baby step did
you just hang yourself I know that's
what I I in my childhood bedroom next to
her I'm like in the notice she made me
do this
no but but she's right like and now I
think about that sometimes I still cave
and I'm like make up a reason to call a
friend or text a friend or a family
member but I'm like yes you you like
we're so scared we never really have to
be alone because of our phones but like
being alone is like it's a great great
thing yeah it's scary though that was so
much of our early years as the comments
oh it's just being in a hotel room and
just being like I have to write because
I'm alone I gotta do it right where now
we take all these people with us and
it's great we've leveled up but it's
like yeah it's less time to write less
time to be creative or we're creative in
another way I guess with the filming and
do podcasts and that's time consuming so
yeah we have we need more content now
and we have less time well that's
something I've been actually actively
thinking about and that's why I think
like I'm trying to get more into like
Finance or like quality over quantity
because I'm like you know I started
comedy and got into comedy because I
didn't want a day job and we've put so
much stuff on our plate that it's a day
job now sure right it's it's a thing
it's a beast you have to feed over and
over and over again yeah and I'm not
saying doesn't have to be like that
because it might just be like this is
the phase where it has to be like that
but I'm trying to actively think of ways
where it doesn't have to be like that
yeah it's like you can just like get out
of it because it's like every week I'll
look at my schedule and I'm like oh I'm
not on the road this week I have nothing
to do and then it's every day it's
podcast meetings this that and it's like
well you realize there's there's power
in saying no to [__] and I think that's
something that we forget because so many
years of just true unpaid gig shitty
paid gig weird thing that you have to
just and they're like you don't ever I'm
a Mike D Stefano you don't say no to
nothing like that's the [__] you would
say you're like all right and then uh
you get to a point where like you can
say no to I mean I had a meeting like
the other like a general meeting and I
was like there was something I want to
do this day and now it's like in the
middle of my day and I was like [__]
this [__] why am I doing there's no
reason by the way with in my opinion too
especially with social media and what we
do for a living there's no reason to
ever ever general meeting you see what I
yes just make the choice man my life is
on my life is on the internet exactly
and we have the same cut you give me a
water you know how you been uh doing the
road yeah we'll be in touch yeah you got
any ideas actually I do okay bye but
like you realize you can say no like you
don't have to do everything like peop I
think people expect us to do everything
and and you don't have to there are days
where you just be like I I'm gonna take
a day off well I think too going back to
Italy that's another thing that I
learned is they're okay with you not
getting better every day and it's a very
American ideology that we have to be the
best and you know we'll always say like
whatever happened to that guy it's like
well to them that's a part of life it's
like you get really big and successful
and whatever and you're good but it's
like if it doesn't always stay going up
that's fine you're going to level off
that's like being a human being where
like we look at that as like no
so-and-so fell off when it can't go
backwards they look at that as like what
are you talking about they had a great
right here last year now they're having
a normal year this year that's part of
life what's the difference no like so
it's just our way of looking at things
sometimes where especially being New
Yorkers and in entertainment it's like
we're always like we got to keep getting
better I don't want to sell a 2 000
Cedar this week and then uh 500 Cedar
next week it's like well if that's what
happens that's what happens you know
that hurts well sometimes you're doing
so much radio and so much so much uh so
many podcasters you're like [__] I got
some more tickets for this gig I'll get
on this podcast I'll do this I'll do
that and then you're like maybe I could
just take a w and not trying to keep
adding shows that too but that but it's
hard for us I think you're right we're
wired in a way where we have to keep
leveling up what I've been doing mostly
now though there's not every weekend but
like for example I just came from Albany
right and uh at the egg great venue and
I could have added a second show I sold
out my show like two months in advance
so I could have easily added a second
show and come close to selling out but I
didn't because I was like what's more
worth it for me we're in Albany the
show's at seven o'clock it's two hours
away from home is is the extra money
that I'm gonna make on the second
sellout worth it to get home at 4am or
have to get home the next day and not be
able to take my kid on the bus to school
or can I get home by 11 30. get a good
night's sleep and take my daughter to
school in the morning and sacrifice the
money and I sacrificed the money and
it's like it was so much better to watch
baseball and that's what the money's for
is to do stuff like that yeah and I do
that a lot now I'm like I can go back
exactly it's like I could have added a
show even in Ithaca if I wanted to say
but you know what instead I got done at
8 30 and I had like a great dinner
[__] runs Upstate New York yeah
baby I'm the [__] real Cuomo
nipple rings and all hell yeah I'll
sexually assault everybody
so so I you know instead had like a
great dinner with my Cannon was on the
road with me hey Mike I had a great
dinner with my Cannon and we had fun and
I was like this is as opposed to you
know eating pizza in between sets right
just being buried in our notebooks not
talking I'm like not everything's money
man like not yes I feel like you gotta
well what I've tried to do is like make
money as a currency that I need from me
and my family to survive but it's not
the only currency I deal in it's like
time is the currency oh huge being away
from my family is the currency so I
evaluate all freedoms Freedom's a
currency so I'm like if I don't want to
do the second show even though it's
leaving money on the table it's like
well that's not the only thing I deal
with I'm getting time back and I'm
getting you know stressed back and and
there's the people will be there next
year yes exactly yeah it's uh unless
there's another Wuhan Weezer
but we're not going anywhere too we're
in this for the Long Haul we'll be doing
comments for years and that's why you
have to protect yourself yes and not run
yourself down I mean look I have a hard
time saying no to gigs like I'm out for
like 12 days at a time but I do kind of
like it but you like it I think here's
the thing if you like it I like it
that's the thing so if you like it you
like it I like not I like you have you
have a family right so so I so but again
but if I didn't I would be like what
what be out of fun but for me it's like
you know I don't uh you know I don't
even with Radio City like you know Burke
was like you should add a second a
second show at Radio City on the same
night we'll sell out quicker than
theater at MSG most likely but I was
like yeah but then I have to do two in
one night it's New York it's big for me
it's my family's gonna be there my
daughter's going to be there I don't
want to yeah then what then I like can't
really focus on them it's like we have a
whole dinner plan like I'd rather just
take my chances do the show the next
night at the theater at MSG and see what
happens maybe I sell it out maybe I
don't and that's another thing too like
with Radio City it you know it sold out
so quick that then we put a theater at
MSG on sale and that wasn't selling as
quick of course and the people in my
team were like oh maybe this is big
maybe this mistaken I was like wait wait
we're forgetting to celebrate the win of
rainbow City like forget about it I'm
glad you said that forget about the
theater at MSG if it sells no tickets
who gives a [__] Rainbow City sold out
yeah that's what this was about great
point so so I've kind of released myself
from it and I've released myself from
like the comparison go go buy Chris oh
yeah yeah
if I don't sell out theater at MSG I'll
kill myself and I might be there in
November so yeah so and then if I kill
myself Sam
[Laughter]
I guess we don't have the Google [__]
but can we get his dates up here yeah
well I got right now on sale is uh the
only thing you can get tickets for is
theater at MSG September 23rd I might be
adding I'm gonna be adding a fall tour
but it's not on sale yet so just go get
those tickets in in New York and check
out his Netflix special she got podcasts
up the yin yang Chrissy chaos hey babe
uh yeah patreon.com Christy comedy yeah
man we're [__] doing it oh yeah and
uh hit me up for your investment advice
yeah and a Netflix special especially
where she Chris is hilarious kind of
essential specials oh yeah uh terrific
comic I'm sure most you know him anyway
but you know yeah thank you man and
James Bodega cat whiskey and thanks for
the all the damn Donuts baby when does
this come out
June 4th oh good day see me I'll be that
week uh yeah you got me Greensboro oh
Greensboro North Carolina Ashley oh the
orange peels great in Nashville I can't
wait Knoxville Memphis moving slowly
help me out guys Birmingham Chattanooga
Nashville Denver uh Santa Fe San Antonio
Houston you get the gist you can't sell
it Memphis you're falling off
you keep saying no to [__] samuel.com
all right I'm already in Australia uh
during this time so if you're there come
see me I can't wait I haven't been in
years got a lot of dates we're adding
shows and uh come on out I'm not coming
back for a while so say hello and then
I'll be announcing a theater tour in
July and that special is coming out in
Late July so
praise all uh good stuff cooking be nice
to yourself get some time get some
Freedom play with your kids say no get a
cupcake and go [__] yourself thanks a
lot Cliff it up thank you guys bye what
an app